so what you see is the exalted form of
the human
and this exalted form of the human is
reflected within society and when you
have the exalted form of the human
society you have what so many people
call utopia it's nothing more than a
conscious humanity where the delusion of
separateness is no longer exist is this
something where we all live on the same
planet together
physically yeah consciously in a
different place yes and the reason that
i say that is because
the the people who are talking about
this concept of the new earth not being
something that takes place physically on
earth or in resistance to physicality
source itself is not in resistance to
physicality there is so much ecstasy to
be experienced in the physical life you
know and it's just going to get better
the same as like if i was to take you
right now and put you back in the 1600s
and to see what the medical practices
are back then you're like yeah you know
it's barbaric so to that to them and
that age this seems like a dream
and i and i'm like sort of trying to
explain that sort of the pain that we
have with our physical experience
doesn't really exist in this new earth
experience
because like even if there if you were
to get out of alignment you know we're
looking at progress in the future and
that's not even all the way to the new
earth like progress in the future where
you get sick and literally you pass
through a light that's able to reset
everything
there's no pain involved in this process
it's oh today i manifested cancer cells
i passed through this light now they're
gone you know and stuff that most of us
cannot conceptualize on from this place
that we're in today it makes me think of
some stories that i've heard from other
people about extraterrestrials and
things that have come to earth that they
were supposed to build and then it
didn't get to happen and things like
that and so then it makes me wonder
about
about the role
about i'm guessing extraterrestrials
exist other entities
yes
um i figured that was the case
um i didn't want to assume so what is
their role then what did
what is their role in our evolution it
depends on the one yeah so let's go
let's go i'll just i'll give an overview
but i mean
it's important for people who are
watching this to know that we're greatly
simplifying concepts for the sake of you
know people being able to understand
things so
yeah this is like in and of itself its
own
a rabbit hole but
i might take you a little ways down the
rabbit hole
all right so when it comes to
extraterrestrials it's a it's really
like across the map what level of
consciousness these beings have and what
role they're playing within the greater
universe you have what we call a
malevolent being universally speaking is
not necessarily a level of being and
this is what's hard for people to grasp
and the way that i kind of spell this is
i could have argument about this but i'm
going to i'm going to just throw this
out there's not a perfect example but
you've probably heard people saying it's
really important for us to
weed a certain population of species out
here otherwise the earth's going to get
in trouble do you think that we are the
villain to that species or the victor
even though we see ourselves this way
we're the villain right we're the bad
guy we're the one that's coming in and
saying i get to be like we're wrecking a
lot of things we are but like we see
ourselves oftentimes as as doing
something beneficial
whereas that's not what is
being perceived by whatever species is
doing their thing wow
so so the first story that i'm going to
essentially tell you about is this the
story where there's extraterrestrial
beings who are considered like universal
scavengers or part of the universal
immune system
okay now if you have a species that is
behaving like a bacterial infection
then it gets targeted by the immune
system of the universe at large which
just so happens to be you know that we
could consider like a t cell
within source to be one of these
extraterrestrial beings
so they they essentially target a
species that's so
acting its own best interest against the
rest of the system that it comes in and
essentially tries to take it out
at the same time as you have an
extraterrestrial being who's like you
know what there's so much value in
humanity we can make humanity choose so
even they are playing into this choice
point where you've got you know these
extraterrestrial beings we're trying to
prove that
the human race is essentially gone rogue
and as a cleanup species meaning it's
one we have to take out of the picture
of the rest of the system because to be
honest with you right now
the amount of collective asking from
earth
from other species
planting the mineral kingdom animal
kingdom that are asking for us to go
is huge it's like a
signal throughout the universe right
not good at the same time as you're
having like a whole whole like other you
know form of extraterrestrial beings and
this is more complicated which have
reached this level of awareness in
general where they understand that there
is nothing in the universe that is not
it and so when there's this
distress call being made by things
around a being that you also are
there's an inherent desire to bring that
aspect back into alignment because you
don't see it as separate to oneself
so there's essentially a war this bigger
war being waged over humanity but it's
not a traditional war
it's the war over what will they choose
if there's influence
so you've got these extraterrestrial
beings trying to influence humanity to
like prove
that you know they are a garbage species
essentially that's causing problems in
the greater universe and world and you
know this whole group which is trying to
put influence on humans to to prove that
they're capable of being like wait i'm
not going to act like a cancer cell i'm
going to tune back into the system and
essentially create a win-win which
they're so capable of doing
so how do these fighter t cells or
whatever we want to call them how do
they get us to try and essentially be
wiped out manipulating the media
but what's important to know is they're
not controlling people they're putting
pressure on people
these extraterrestrial beings no matter
it doesn't matter what e.t you talk to
right
all of them understand the concept of
free will and choice all of them have to
operate within this you know the primary
laws that govern our universe like law
of attraction which is why you know you
there's no such thing as like a what we
call a gray there's no such thing as a
gray alien is from zeta reticuli there's
no such thing as them coming in and
doing an abduction on somebody who
hasn't already experienced some form of
powerlessness at the hands of an abuser
or whatever it doesn't happen
so they're still they're operating
within you know the rules within this
greater universe they can't not they
understand choice
so so it's like they're not able to
control you neither they're able to
influence
so they're going to influence through
you know anything that makes humanity go
towards the ego things like fear things
like you know greed things like envy you
know all of these
experiences that can catch people and
cause them to you know separate at the
same time as you've got the other ones
who are essentially like no love no tune
into people no
and we're kind of seeing where humanity
kill yourself feel your emotions yeah
like i don't have time i got this other
thing going on i'm my ego's calling the
ego game that is a that is a that is a
clawing game and in fact it
makes me think of certain times where i
feel like i've had egoic deaths along
the way
there's a like a like a one or two
rounds of like a last chance clawing and
it really seems like that where these
weird like talons come out and you say
and do things that you're like the hell
was that like i've made so much progress
that was terrible and it feels like
there's like this vicious coming for you
and is that is that a phase that we're
in where we just need to like
endure this sort of vicious phase that's
happening where
this division and this sort of choice
game is really challenging we have to
embrace the fact that there is this
massive challenge of the pressure cooker
of this awakening that i'm describing
but what
what we must do is to aggressively love
the ego
and that's what nobody's doing and it's
a struggle for me even because you know
english language again when i'm here
telling you that the ego is doing
something super bad the natural
reflection for a human is to be like all
right then we gotta push the ego away
well that's how it wins right there and
and it's not even about a wing losing
game the ego is incredibly beneficial
but unless we really spend time to
understand it and figure out how to meet
its needs and by doing so
come in as a kind of like you know i'm
caretaking the ego as a tool of my own
rather than it's the thing that runs me
we're not going to be able to make this
transition happen
how do we do that how do we how do we
make friends with the ego how do we love
the ego how do we understand the ego
you understand the value of having self
you understand the value of the aspects
of self
and by virtue of understanding the value
you know what place to put it in you
know
i think the recognition of the ego is
the first step you know most people it's
like it's a very complicated prop you
know practice it's like you can look at
buddhist monks for example you've got
people who have taken themselves out of
society put themselves in a monastery
and they're practicing this for 80 years
straight
so it's even more difficult when you're
in the world and you've got so many
triggers for the ego but the recognition
of the ego which is this perception of
separate self is the first step
to recognize when any aspect of you is
fighting for self
in any way and to not make that wrong
it's just the recognition you know and
that's what we call that that external
witnessing or the the some people call
this detachment or disidentification
people say interesting i am watching
teal you know if i'm doing me i am
watching teal
have a a reaction to the fact that this
person
has achieved something i have not
achieved
what does that tell me about myself and
it's like you're almost approaching it
like you would
i don't want to like belittle the ego by
saying it's like a child but
there's a very loving way you can
approach a child when it's in that state
how do i empower the self so it's not in
the state where it's grasping you know
how do i sit with my emotions to allow
myself to understand that the way that
it feels makes sense
and it all of this process causes a
calming down of in the integration of
the ego and so what we end up with
eventually is the conscious ego which
most people don't
understand as a state that exists most
people think consciousness is when you
get rid of the ego i think it's the
worst thing we've ever taught honestly
[Music]